hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to papers please
we are now allowing oh god who are you
hi are you gonna take your whoa oh
my god that's so nice highlight
discrepancies well you see i don't
really have a gun and a sword as
problems here hello hi it is too early
to come all the way out here the smell
of this checkpoint makes me sick
what is that hanging there these
walls are for official plaques only
your pay will be deduct for violation at
least your performance is not terrible
you have received 15 silent citations do
not slip further
now i have an old friend coming through
approve her entry shay
piersovska shay piersovska
i have a black and i have art
yay that's nice that's real nice
that's real nice yeah that's good okay
the division authority of east crescent
corporations will visit again today
okay that's fine and then shea purba
okay let's get this show on the road hi
welcome come on in
hi how are you you shay nah
move here this looks good dates good
great rap my
notes okay
what was the problem okay united
federation great rabbit okay that's good
this doesn't look like you at all
oh yeah yeah the slowdowns with this
crap
uh
okay this is not right
sorry goodbye look you forged your
identity i can't risk anyone getting
through that shouldn't get through
this is just the way it be so shush
hey again hi how are you assassin coming
from integra will target important music
agents
his name is caleb khalid istam okay
khaledistum
oh god okay do not touch powder
oh god oh oh god oh god oh
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh oh god
be 12 weeks uh okay
yes you're right why you got to say it
like that republia les randi
yep permit looks good on this
ah there's a problem here as the
document says
well look look here i gotta i gotta
check these things i gotta check these
things i am legally obligated to check
these things apparently
um
well you're about to know something
about this you're about to know
i've forgotten what the name of the dude
is oh
god what was the name of the dude
lashrandi la scrundy leber stundy
oh
oh god no oh
god no oh god no
ah um ah
ah
i don't know i have no idea what was the
name of the dude i've forgotten
every name that i needed to know uh
rita decu
okay 199 okay 66 okay date of birth
matches up
you're not a wanted fugitive everything
looks good here
have a good day
[Music]
invalid height but it looked okay to me
oh
crap oh boy i'm gonna live with your
wife huh well i'll see about that
name matches up goatee yep that's okay
looks good to me
i've forgotten the name of the people
that need to i've entirely forgotten
i've completely forgotten i have no idea
who it was cal
khalid khalid khalid khaled is khalid
istam
khalid istam
[Music]
okay
yeah that's fine totally fine
totally fine ah don't mind that buddy
it's all good thanks khalid
have a good one that was the one i was
supposed to kill right
and the other one was like shea
something shea butter
shea butter shay shea you shay shay
what's happening oh
oh
[Music]
that's a big fine for the hangings
i don't think i let in shea either
mysterious poison hospitalizes several
hospitalizes doesn't just kill
all right sure this is fine that was all
good
this is all great actually very good
actually
extremely great special program for
political asylum has been established
though seeking asylum must carry the
valid
grant of asylum entrance with such a
grant do not require an entry permit or
an id supplement
okay that's good and poor
uh oh spaghettios you got a problem
i'm just gonna deny you because i know
it's a problem get out of here
i'm not gonna detain you i can get more
money if i just go faster on these
anyway
what do you mean what oh god the denial
reason oh my god
all right you look good here just go
i'm not even gonna check anything else
oh the things are better here they're
not they're really not
red stamp give me the red stamp i'm
serious
i have a better job offering in poor red
stamp and i can break contract in
arsos get 10 credits to you cool sounds
good to me
you don't need to tell me twice you're
welcome take care buddy
hear me out what what
[Music]
okay
well it makes sense to me you know what
it might have questioned it go on
have a good one all right sure man
sure you'll pick it up in a few days
sure okay hi what's up
uh oh the hell is that
whoa what the hell oh god wait a minute
whoa
you could shoot oh god me uh oh oh god
oh god oh god oh god
no my buddy now
screw down no no
no hello mr alt
f4 not gonna let my buddy die i was not
ready for that
plus that person shouldn't have gotten a
tranquilizer should have been a gun gun
i didn't know if i
had a gun gun i know there's two
keyholes but i didn't know if one of
them actually was a gun that could be
used
let's try that again shall we
oh here we go here we go here we go here
we go
hello and got him okay and we're good
and we're good
we lost someone but hey it was
completely unavoidable
been a lot of terrorist attacks your
sister has been arrested
huh her young daughter needs a home
[Music]
blah how in the hell would you ever
be able to afford that
oh you save on heating costs
no but wait i
can't afford to adopt and
bob well sorry niece
i can't afford it apparently daring bike
attack at graston checkpoint extremists
growing bolder
grestin like magnet integrion
whistleblower arrives disappears
immediately oh that's not my fault
definitely not my fault hi okay here we
go
hi how you doing there's more action at
this checkpoint and then in the war
i thought it'd collect you for five
years if you think it's bad in arstotzka
it's 10 times worse than kalechia
i do not blame them for coming here
anyway you were doing well keep it up
yeah i saved your life i guess that's
good
okay well i really gotta make some money
because maybe i need to adopt
my niece so if i can get through a whole
day without anyone blowing anything up
it'd be really great
okay hey welcome come on in hi how you
doing quick quick quick quick come on
come on let's go let's go let's go
date's good job here
oh my god where's your other piece of
paperwork
uh id god of course you haven't
okay weight is good height is good
whatever
good okay name is good name matches
the that's good okay passport matches
dates good
work good what did you say two months
yep okay this is taking way too long in
poor thank you
my god that was a lot of info
go go go go get get get get out of here
get get get get go
that took so long wow god explore oh
i'm never gonna make any money i'm never
gonna make any money i'm never gonna
make
any money ever hi again
remember me maybe gars kickers
give you that great banner oh cool good
to see you again
tell my coach about this he get very
upset say if i do not get banner back i
lose
front seat on bus team all seats good
but front seat very best so i need the
banner back
what do you say i say take it my dude
there take it it's more beaten up than i
remember even
there's a big tear what did you do i
just had it hanging up dude shut up how
like what what do you want from me i
gave you your so go away
yeah i'll rude for you if i survive that
long
a-hole hi again
hey what's up hey same procedure you
know it man you know what's up
dates good here name's good there
that's uh seals good there mustache
there
what the hell do you have there you got
more drugs
it's a real mystery that's for sure it's
it's a real mystery
maybe things get too sexy in here yeah
maybe
maybe my dude maybe my dude maybe maybe
god what what is what is this
what is this
[Music]
okay sure
so far everything's smooth like ice
thanks to you yep
thanks bud appreciate that very much
thank you
live with wife okay sounds good
hmm it is probably as
as they say here we are
that matches up hmm hmm
yeah i shouldn't i probably shouldn't do
so many detainings i probably shouldn't
for a little discrepancy like that but
oh god now i feel bad about that uh
am i supposed to feel bad about this
because over time i just start to feel
bad about everything
i feel bad about denying people i feel
bad about all this
what if it's that what is that
used to have a watch like that sell it
to me
for sure he's not coming back let me
take it off your hands and no
off off dude just take this
and go
shut up go ahead he's gonna come back
i'm not
man i think this is one of those games
where it just makes you feel like you
actually
like it's easy to get lost in it it's
it's easy to just be like yeah it's just
paperwork but
when you start to think of it like
people that actually need to
live their lives and and are trying to
like just get by it's oh
i shouldn't feel emotional about this
all right all tan sure date of birth
matches
168 178 yeah it all looks good
[Music]
glory to ours why
invalid name eat my ass
you got my invalid ass in your name ah
what is this this is not red this is not
the right symbol what is this
what is this
sure you do
uh are these guys just getting hauled
off to die
is that is that the is that the actual
thing that happening here amount of time
i got through 12 god i'm never gonna
make it
i'm never gonna make this this is just a
beer
i feel like this was starting out as a
very fun game and it's
actually starting to weigh on my soul
i feel like the choices that i'm making
are actually having an impact on my
mental well-being
oh my god i can only go back so much but
good god oh i feel bad man
i feel bad i feel actually bad
polio resurfaces holy oh
freaking polio let me guess we're not
getting oh
hi
what's with uh what's with uh that your
position is important and your
responsibilities are broad
follow all protocols strictly what's uh
what's going on there
with um what's the deal um do people
turn bright red
from head to toe when they got polio is
that what happens i don't know
oh hi hello how are you
i'll dealt with another assassin comes
man in red carries info on all lasik
can i take chances you must kill him
today we will provide opportunity to
succeed you will be caught
must sacrifice sell for oh
oh oh
[Music]
guy behind me in land would not shut up
about on and on how about how important
it was
look his good watch i can see give you
no says he can no i'm not gonna
no shut up i'm not gonna do that i might
just
reject you just for being meanie there
you go take it get out of here get out
of here
hey what's up dude i sure do i sure do
there you go buddy
thanks pal
there's a new scratch give money back
i'm gonna give you money back just go
just go man
yeah forget it i will keep the money
because i might have to shoot someone
i guess oh hello person in red
what what what is what is uh
uh person in well okay this doesn't seem
like
okay
wait oh god no
okay here we go it's happening it's time
we're going to open both of these up
we're going to get this one
bam got it and then immediately with
this one
oh no oh there got him okay jesus
christmas
oh you are under arrest for the murder
of an innocent
but am i the penalty is
oh wait hang on a second
wait hold on wait
family will be questioned about their
involvement wait what
but the border will remain open under a
replacement inspect wait
wait wait wait what wait
wait but a note appears from under the
cell door
inspector family is safe target
eliminated but other problems arise
replacement inspector not cooperative
easy activities hindered
we cannot provide further support hezik
to hibernate again
family will be taken to oberston good
luck
oh oh
ending nine of 20
of 20 okay holy
um
wow the big game so that's it for this
episode
i don't know if i'm going to try a
completionist route of this game
i don't think i will uh but yeah wow
for the glory of arstoszka you know for
the glory of her sousa
honestly they were kind of dicks to me
anyway it didn't really help they got
all my savings taken away really helping
those guys
it did me no good absolutely none of
that was very helpful at all
i didn't make very much money i wasn't
doing very good
and i just generally kind of everything
was kind of sucky
and you know the fact of detaining
people took longer than it was just to
actually
deny them made it me realize that i
should have just been denying and not
detaining in the first place because the
money that i was getting from that
wasn't even really enough to
make a difference i could have gotten
more money just by getting more people
going through
okay but hey that was fun you know
that's a good game
it really makes you think and it really
makes you feel things and even though i
cheated a whole bunch
hey that's what life's all about baby
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and if you want me to get
to another ending if i didn't get to the
official ending or something like that
or if there's a super secret ending
maybe i'll consider it but
you know you'll have to really talk me
into it so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you